um
oh yeah it's time to twist and shout and
celebrate 16 years of the beatles love
and to help us understand all the
celebrations going wrong we have going
on we have marquis san feliz she's the
dance coach of the popular cirque show
for the last three years right yes i've
been the dance coach for the last year
and i performed in the show before that
okay and then you've been with cirque
itself for now almost nine years yeah
it's fantastic yeah well thank you for
being here today celebrating 16 years
and we're gonna have some fun with this
we decided marquee and i that we would
see how many beatles titles we can work
into this conversation all right so
jc said he's going to try to keep score
for us over there i think we have a
little ding every time we like perhaps
hit on one so uh i'm back to the
interview you you just stole one you did
you just
oh my gosh he's like eleanor ridley that
guy i just
just let it be just let it be there you
go i know we just got to come together
and be kind to each other yeah all right
so tell us about the show what's
different now uh we through this uh last
year we've been able to refresh the show
a little bit it's really exhilarating
it's really exciting we have uh
trampolines and aerialists and acrobats
and dancing which makes it uh beautiful
so there are different acts from when we
first started
until now and different cast members too
of course coming in and out yeah it's
been 16 years but in some ways it seems
just like yesterday
oh you got me yeah right
that was a good one
is there anything different going on are
you going to have a big night that's
like celebrating the 16 years we're
celebrating tonight we're just very
excited to celebrate tonight 2006 16
years ago today uh it's it's really
something
there you go okay she didn't even she
didn't even need help on that one
[Laughter]
you are you've been an on-call dancer
which means if somebody's sick you jump
in yes but now you coach how does that
work what do you do it's really fun i
get to
uh bring in new artists and teach them
the show and then throughout that i uh
keep the show fresh and give notes to
the performers as the days go on 460
shows a year wow sergeant pepper and hey
jude and get back just now you're just
naming songs yeah
now do you guys perform eight days a
week we perform
we perform five
five days a week okay all right we have
two shows a night seven and nine thirty
okay tuesdays through saturday that's
it's so much fun and for are you a
beatles fan or were you before the show
i was a beatles fan before the show but
now i really enjoy their music it's
timeless it's classic it's iconic it is
it's so much fun and there's some dreamy
type sequences that are throwback to
perhaps some enhancements that the
beatles may have oh yeah we have our dr
roberts character that goes out in the
audience and gets the audience involved
too so in a way yeah i mean with a
little help from your friends it becomes
an even better show
yes it does
oh it's listen it's been a long and
widened road to get to this point but
no no no we listen really all you need
is love to do this this is all you do
very nice to put up with this first of
all i love it
i love games i'm not doing very well but
i'm enjoying it if you happen to be in
the show where could we see you uh i am
not in the show i know but if you if i
happen
there you go yeah yeah do people come up
to you all the time because you're very
attractive and say i want to hold your
hand
no they don't okay that was a good one
congratulations on 16 years thank you
the beatles love performs tuesday
through saturday 7 and 9 30 p.m inside
the mirage hotel and casino tickets can
be purchased at cirque du soleil.com how
about that jc i counted i don't know at
least 25 songs